you'll know our next guest from just
about everything you've seen on screen
in recent years dylan mcdermott has
played in dozens of roles in movies and
tv shows like hollywood the practice one
of my favorites still magnolias and
american horror story just to name a few
now he's starring in fbi most wanted as
supervisory special agent remy scott
right here on cbs he leads a fugitive
task force tracking down notorious
criminals in tonight's episode agent
scott and the team they search for a
murderer mimicking the crimes of a
notorious 80s mobster take a look oh
it's all there yeah i remember
jackie the fox bianchi yeah right wow
you remember the eighties you don't
i wasn't even born to finish that
sentence
jackie the fox was suspected of multiple
mob hits and even spent time in the most
wanted list how'd he get off it he died
i think he blew up in a boat or
something right mr old school
first on cbs mornings dylan mcdermott
joins us how you doing good morning good
so great to be here so glad to have you
listen we want to start by saying
congratulations the show uh picked up
for two more seasons two more usually
you get the one more scene
this by the way this never happened so
so what was your reaction when you heard
the news i was blown away were you
sitting by the phone
um of course yes
yeah because this this time of year is
always a little anxious because you know
you never know if the show's gonna be
picked up or was that it but when it
comes down there's a two-year pickup
right that's huge stability stability
right yeah that just shows how well the
show is doing right yes absolutely and
how good you are in the show thank you
the same so thank you what was it like
stepping into a lead role in a show
that's already been around for two
seasons and that will be two more but
that must have been a tricky scenario no
you know it was interesting because i
was on organized crime which is also a
dickwolf show and um i was on for two
seasons um so when i got the call that
he wanted me to come on it was sort of a
natural transition because he was
already the executive producer so they
knew my style of work they knew what i
was going to bring so it seemed like it
was rather seamless to come on to
another show but this time to play a
good guy you just wrapped that show and
then
so what did dick wolf say to convince
you
uh he asked
and when he asked
you do it yeah so speaking of your style
and what you bring to the role you say
you always bring something real from
yourself from your actual person that's
right the job into the role uh
care to share what that was this time
you know i was able to create the
character from the ground up which is
amazing and um i talked to dick and
david hutchins the the show runner about
how to how to keep myself rooted in this
character and i wanted him to have loss
in his life
i had lost in my life early on and i
thought it was great to
use that for this character because it
would fuel me and anchor me in this role
for years to come
and that's proven to be true already
i can always refer and go back to that
anytime
when i'm playing remy scott so um i try
to use pieces of my life whenever i can
because i just think it adds that extra
element that's never i that i you know i
sometimes see on tv or you cannot see
that authenticity always pull from
exactly what was the loss in your life
early on i lost my mom early on yes i do
remember so i think that yeah you know
and in the show i lost my brother but i
do think that law sometimes does fuel
people
um to carry on
you know it was also reported that you
didn't want to meet your cast mates
until the first day of filming what was
your strategy there normally people have
a get getting to know you dinner
because you didn't you decided i'm going
to wait till the first day yeah i really
wanted my first yeah my first day of
filming i i really wanted to be what
it's like to meet people like like today
right you know there's there's always
like hey i'm just getting to know you
and you know you're not sure it's a
little awkward i wanted all that in the
scene
and uh that proved to be true
we didn't feel awkward meeting you
well we met before again yes we it was
not awkward at all you came come bring
in those baby blues there's a great line
in the in the first show it says where
you're wooing someone i won't say who
you said i don't do practical i do
impulsive because life is more fun that
way
and i thought about that line i thought
am i practical or impulsive
are you practical or impulsive
i think i'm a little bit of both you
know it's a it's a lot easier to be
impulsive on tv yes yes yeah yeah in
real life because you know how it's
going to turn out speaking of being a
little bit of both um you have played
villains
you have played complicated characters
if you will um you've also played good
guys yep um so what is more fun what do
you like to dive in more when it comes
to a character um i mean i love doing
the character work you know as if i as
i've gotten older
i just really enjoy
creating a character
um like i did in hollywood you know that
guy was so interesting too and layered
and to do the research and to meet
people and
to find out you know what they eat and
how they dress and
how they walk and why they do those yeah
why all that stuff the psychology of the
character it's like dylan you do
homework i like what nate said in the
beginning about the practice because i
love the problem i love that show oh you
know a lot of people talk about reboot
this reboot that yeah is that something
you would even consider or are
interested in doing you found one of my
i mean never say never you just don't
know um right now my home is fbi most
wanted and i'll be there for a while
after that i just don't know it's such a
political answer like right now
my mind is on governing the state of
pennsylvania and i'll think about the
election when it comes like the practice
birthed a whole bunch of shows just like
yeah yeah it's true yeah it's true well
listen we appreciate you dylan mcdermott
you're one of the best and thank you
thank you for coming by see the practice
review although i do love fbi most
wanted to write about that and speaking
of political you can watch fbi
right here on cbs tonight at 10 9
central